ازمه جديده تطرق ابواب المواطنين هنا في
مخيم جباليه شمال قطع غزه في ظل انعدام
كامل للحياه والحصول على المواد الاساسيه
لكن الان هناك صعوبه في الحصول على ماء
صالحه للشرب وايضا الماء الغير صالحه
اصبحت غير متوفره في ظل انعدام كامل لابار
المياه بعد قصف الاحتلال هذه الابار وقصف
محطات التحليه اصبح المواطنون يعانون في
الحصول على جزء يسير وجزء بسيط من المياه
من اجل سد عطشهم ومن اجل الاستمرار في
الحياه كما نشاهد هنا المئات من المواطنون
يحاولون الحصول على جزء بسيط من المياه في
ظل انعدام كامل لابار المياه في شمال قطاع
غزه وصعوبه الحصول على هذه المياه هنا
يصطفون ساعات من اجل الحصول على جزء بسيط
من هذه المياه وهي ايضا غير صالحه للشرب
ايضا وغير صالحه للاست استخدام لكنهم
مضطرون لذلك ومضطر للحصول عليها هنا في
شمال قطع
غزه زي ما انتم شايفين من صباح الله من
صلاه الصبح ونحنا صفين دور على المي وهذه
المي لا تصلح للشرب ولا تصلح للغسيل وهي
زي ما انتم شايفين مجاري بنعوم في المجاري
واولادنا حافيين وبعدين ايش احنا بدنا حلش
هذا شوفونا حلنا شي هذا منصف من الصبح
بحصل يمكن نحصل على قل بربه بعدين بم لهم
دون ميه بنحط الكرادي اللي مش نستنى
الشتاء ينزل عشان نضب ميه بستنى الشتاء
ينزل عشان نضب ميه للغسيل ولجلي وهذا بدنا
حل هذا هذا
الله
دتنا واحنا ففين في الدور مش معي كل اللي
راح وابن عمي
ستشد كله عشان نعب بس القربه الله
اكبر حرام اللي بيصير
فينا من الصبح من الفجر من الفجر الله
اكبر وبنشوف دور من امبارح والمي صارت يوم
بعد
يوم وين الميه متنا من السقع ونا منشور
الله تميت يومين من الميه من الرس كمان
بحركو في الخشب الخشب بحركو الله
اكبر ما بنحصل على طعام ولا على مياه حتى
بيم في الوضع بتيم في غسيل كل اسبعين مره
بتتغسل الناس كل يوم في البر بنحصل على في
الوقفه الساعه من الفجر لاخر النهار بنحصل
على قلن واحد لما نعبي ميه كله الجنن
بيجيش 20 لتر اطلع ازمه المياه طلع معسكري
منطقه الشمال كله بيشتغل عبير واحد كله
والله شغال عبير واحد اطلعوا
كيف قصف وتجويع ونقص للمياه هكذا هي
الحياه هنا في شمال قطاع غزه في ظل انعدام
كامل للمقومات الاساسيه حيث هنا المواطن
يصطف لساعات من اجل الحصول على جزء من
المياه للاستمرار في الحياه انس الشريف
الجزيره شمال غزه